on Wednesday the Supreme Court heard oral arguments
about whether or not states can refuse to provide
abortions to women whose health is in grave danger
that is where we are at right now
case involves Idaho's strict total abortion ban
which says that patients can only receive abortions if their life is at danger
if they are literally about to die
but see there's this federal law from the 90s called EMTALA
and EMTALA says
that if a patient comes to the hospital with an emergent medical condition
the hospital needs to stabilize that patient
so for example
if a pregnant patient comes to the hospital at risk of septic shock
uncontrolled hemorrhaging
loss of organs
loss of future fertility
and an abortion is what that patient wants
and it would stabilize that patient's condition
the hospital must provide it
see how the federal law is more broad
the state law only kicks in if required to save the woman's life
not necessarily her health
but the broader federal law trumps state law
so what's Idaho to do
Idaho's like look
when you overturned Roe v
Wade and Dobbs v
Jackson Women's Health
you gave abortion rights back to the states
so leave us alone
we can deny women healthcare if we want to
oral arguments
Justice Sotomayor was like okay
well under your theory
then a state could also pass a law
saying that women cannot receive abortions under any conditions
even if necessary to save her life
the attorney for the Biden administration
Elizabeth Preloger
was like yes
states do get to decide an abortion
which states have done
but you don't get to criminalize essential healthcare like under EMTALA
states have never been able to criminalize or prevent hospitals from providing
necessary emergent healthcare
Preloger and the courts
three Liberal justices point out the horror of accepting Idaho's legal argument
women will unnecessarily suffer
women will die
women will have to utilize unnecessary resources
like take a helicopter just to get to a state
just to get basic care
and as Preloger points out
all in the pursuit of nothing
doing this
when there's really no possible upside in these situations for the fetus
and somehow it's not entirely clear how the justices are going to rule
we can safely assume that the courts
three Liberal justices
Sotomayor, Kagan
and Ketanji Brown Jackson will side with the Biden administration
and that based on everything we know about them and oral arguments
that Thomas Gorsuch
and Alito will side with Idaho
so that leaves our reproductive fate with Coney Barrett
Kavanaugh and Roberts
who weren't 100% transparent
and oral arguments with how they're going to rule
but that is definitely not three people
who you want deciding your reproductive fate
okay let's pause
did this help you understand what the case is about
what questions do you have
let me know in the comments